اذا مشاهدينا موسكو وكيف بين مد وجزر
روسيا تشن هجوما جويا باحدى وثلاثين مسيره
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه اسقطت القوات
الاوكرانيه 29 مسيره منها طبعا هذا بحسب
كيف بدورها ردت باطلاق ثماني مسيرات
بمنظومه
وضواحيها صباح اليوم حسبما ذكرت الدفاع
الروسيه والتي اكدت بدورها ان دفاعاتها
الجويه قد تصدت للمسيرات الاوكرانيه وايضا
دمرت جميعها قبل وصولها للعاصمه ورغم
تدميرها الا ان بعضها سقط في منطقه تدعى
لكنها قريبه من مقر اقامه بوتين الرسمي
وعدد كبير من كبار رجال الاعمال الروس
وايضا كبار المسؤولين الحكوميين وذلك بحسب
ما نقلت صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيا مساعد
الرئيس الاوكراني نفى دور بلاده في الهجوم
بالمسيرات على موسكو المسؤول الاوكراني
اكد ان الهجوم المضاد يهدف الى العوده
لحدود 91 واستعاده القرم مشددا على وجود
فرص جديه لتحقيق اختراق عبر هجوم مضاد
وذلك خلال الصيف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات